house comras you know what that means
it's time for some more wolf among us
this time we're on this is episode 4
already yep we're on episode 4 in
sheep's clothing
last episode I felt like was really the
ending I feel like it really kicked off
you know we had a lot of mystery about a
lot of [ __ ] going on but nothing too
much had happened I really liked the
last episode I hope ever before it's
gonna be just as good only one way to
find out let's play together bros as
always I will make the best decision for
human you're going to the farm it's as
simple as that
do you have any idea how much it costs
to have an entire family in Glamour I
actually have no fun it's the mirror
it's missing a piece Cree must have
taken a shark with him the open arms
enjoy your stay thanks Big B and thanks
for covering for me last time too baby
how could you do this to me I guess I
finally see you for who you are too long
did it just tell me who did it no you
know I don't think he did it
what look at him do you really think
this man murdered these women
whoa [ __ ] Mary oh yeah we killed him
it was a good show but you know just
take him okay take crane so now we have
to oh Jesus really I mean it yeah out
with the old in with the new along with
the Queen the bad guys had taken away
Hey
some of your brothers are saying that
you know that green flying such a guy is
like working undercover or some [ __ ] I
was thinking about that and it would
make a lot of sense so we can reverse I
thought the doctor said that a for you
batch
oh we got some help maybe oh [ __ ]
see you around uh-oh what point bullets
are a nasty business
a silver slug deformed and shredded on
impact he'll be okay though hmm he'll be
okay his internal organs are positively
riddled ray don't if I don't extract
every single scrap of silver he's liable
to suffer some long-term toxicosis easy
there to move oh god he's mean this way
old boy I figured I'd be done before you
were conscious but there's little I can
do for the pain just stay still and let
me finish my arm yes
very ugly not life-threatening I can't
say the same for these bullets peppered
throughout your vital organs huh I'm
digging in there doc don't move it
doctor look I'm a bit engaged saving his
life at the moment but if the fractured
extremity concerns him that much he can
set it himself
yay let's do it all is gonna be bad oh
come on they just love doing this to us
don't they okay buddy it didn't really
work that well all right here we go
again
okay I'm tapping the kill and reach me
up we're pulling it over seriously come
on yeah
oh here we do it oh we popped it in
there good good job there fella
hmm not bad I don't do I suppose what
he's lucky to be alive and he won't be
next time if he keeps going like this
well he keeps the faint enemy before
maybe he'll listen to you I don't know
about that
well you should there are limits to what
even I can do this is the job he's the
banner Wyatt just relax
excuse me miss white but perhaps it'd be
better if you gave me a few minutes to
finish with him I think I should stay at
least until he's out of the woods leave
me
Big B couldn't be in better hands and I
need the space to work so if you
wouldn't mind we'd appreciate the
Headroom
don't worry snow I'll be okay we'll be
down in a moment just please give us the
time this is why be he why that matter
now ruin that poor chair - hey Doc how
much longer Colin
leave him be it's finished when it's
finished cuz I once watched a vet saw a
turtle together in ten minutes flat Owen
you're not even supposed to be here
right now
oh really where am I supposed to be I'm
here to take care of my friend
Oh with what your it's under that one
listen keep it down back there
thank you can I get some quiet in here
yes that would be helpful sorry my I
mean say to hurry I'm instead of Colin
there all done now that was right this
isn't a habit you should keep doing
having visits with me and well this time
this time was no joke eat as many metal
shellings as you see fit but take just
one more silver round near your heart
and the only place I'll be visiting you
is the morgue miss white
you'll be fine for light duty if he can
figure out what that means he knows what
it means it's just been an unusual
couple of days I know but please don't
give him the excuse it's gonna happen
his body will eventually give out take
care of him please we got none
I will choice you'll need rest I assume
sleep mostly just keep watch and make
sure he doesn't get into further
altercations I'll try
I'm right here guys come on anyways
guard against as they say miss white
sheriff Colin Sweeney hahahaha what you
can't call him at that done did leaders
make any aah
what his next step for us now we're so
lives right
of course a beer Melton so how do you
feel it's big beasts no he'll be okay
he'll I seen him take worse don't worry
about me all right I'll be fine
see strong as an oak this guy you has uh
you had us worried there for a while I
ship them so much
you uh you stopped breathing
you know when you passed out or or I'd I
guess
it um it kind of scared the hell out of
me I've never seen you like that and
when Swinehart arrived you know him he's
never worried and even he thought you
were snow I'd never leave you
yeah you were really [ __ ] up man god
dammit Kalyn when you take an action
figure and bend its limbs the wrong way
Alan I'm just saying I was worried about
him as all the guy hasn't had a night's
rest in days well I'll get some rest
when this whole thing is done what whole
thing what's even happening out there I
mean do you guys have like a plan or
something we don't really know who
should I be asking should I be worried
about The Crooked Man taken over or is
crane still the thing The Crooked Man
Bloody Mary
the Tweedles this is bigger than what I
thought it was yep
yeah The Crooked Man came out of the
shadows for a reason for him to attack
us so blatantly like that he either
feels invincible or desperate well if
those are my two options I don't think
I'd pick desperate me you traded crane
to save Big B I'm just saying that's not
exactly something you do when you're
playing with house money so he called my
bluff it's not like I'm gonna let Bloody
Mary just murdered
it was a split-second decision and I
don't care how it looked
yeah thanks snow for all that back there
no problem thanks you're not pissed that
cranes flown the coop for that the comb
they're not important she's got snow
under his thumb
we're all mad about it Colin but it's
not like we had a strong choice in the
matter
what else could snow do she didn't hand
him over my ass would be down the
witching well crane still would have
been taken ok ok I'll take your word for
it
oh thank you but right now is just what
does The Crooked Man want out of this
I thought he was just a loan shark but
clearly he's operating in other circles
hmm it can't just be about crane right
getting him out of town is this all
about the murders crane can't be useful
to him anymore so what could this have
to do with faith and Lily Greene was a
puppet and the crooked man worked the
strings this is all about control of
Fabletown
yeah but then what do prostitutes have
to do with it Lily
and faith they can keep a secret that's
not how it all works out yet but I know
it does somehow the crooked man declared
war against us last night at least
that's what I thought when it happened
but now I see this war has been going on
for years
we just haven't noticed it because our
way of doing things is broken
pretty much you need to do things the
right way what does that mean the right
way what do you think I mean more bacon
Trevor well but it suspiciously sounds
like your way Bigby's the one on the
front lines you can't give him a leash
he doesn't work that way look I know
things haven't gone great recently but
we're still doing our best that's not
good enough
Dease so starting now we do everything
cut and dried by the book straight as an
arrow
why is driven snow of course not saying
I'm the arbiter of sure you're not haha
this town has enough monsters what
happened last night what you turned into
it can't happen again why not I need
monsters the fight monsters Colin if I
really believed that we needed him to
lose his flippin mind at a moment's
notice
and that would mean I'd lost all faith
and our ability to help this town we
were under attack snow what did you
expect me to do yeah there are degrees
why these I only ever do what's
necessary yeah exactly
yeah well it's kind of the case he's
explained to Colin why tearing dumbs
throat out was necessary Oh about that
at that
it's what I do okay the fight was known
can't let up until the fight is finished
he was he was still a threat and that's
all there is to it
Nara she look Vicki I care about how
this is done just as much as I care
about it getting done so for that you
want to give him a handicap like the bad
guys will worry if [ __ ] gets sloppy
everybody wants Big B to smile and shave
and take a shower now innit
well I'm practically the president of
the Big B don't be such a dick Club
relaxed Khan you speak for myself okay
he'll get the job done just let him do
it I'm going to I'm going to let you do
it
okay it's just that now that I'm deputy
mayor
I need your respect wait the pigs are
mine and this situation has to end
what situation all unglamorous Abel's
starting today have to go and stay at
the fog Jimmy are you gonna let her talk
to me like that it's been the rule for a
reason Colin and think we knows it's for
the best of the town snow says that's
the way it's got to be that's the way
it's got it what are you kidding me
I'm sorry Colin simply get a glamour get
a glamour with what money you think I
can work I don't even have thumbs Wolf's
residence that's rude Oh buff can what
is it okay I'll let him know
Thanks guess who's waiting in your
office right now
I know who Nerissa no risk I knew it
didn't know that what from the puddin
and pie yes apparently she told buff Ken
that she has something she needs to talk
to you about but that she'll only tell
you what do you think that could be aa
Big B's got an admirer you always do
well with the disenfranchised about your
prickly demeanor attracts him like a
moth to a flame she knows something
she's helped me a little with the case
maybe she has something else maybe she
does I should get back to the business
office
I've left buff Ken alone
for too long taking calls and I should
probably change out of these clothes
probably in consider the discussion
tabled but not over let me know when
you're done with Nerissa III captain
she's a piece of work
hey you're not really gonna send me to
the farm are ya
I mean she seemed real serious about it
but I can still hang out here look maybe
a few will get sent up but you're my
friend Khan I wouldn't do that to you
don't worry about it
thanks Big B anytime Fetty I choose
friendship over the rules watch come on
dad dad I have an apple would you send
your friend to farm even if it's a pig
maybe I don't know I like how that shirt
like lives through everything maybe it's
time for attack
stephanie's Bruce
I'm sorry I'm I'm so sorry bros but I'm
gonna have to in the episode here so
will you like to wait until tomorrow for
the next one go ahead and leave me like
if you enjoyed watching this episode I
really appreciate it thanks for always
doing it every day I bet that means one
you're awesome for doing that thank you
that being said I'll see you tomorrow
stay awesome bros